[Music]
when it comes to criminal investigations
law enforcement is learning how social
media can help crack cold cases some
going back decades eleven-year-old linda
o'keefe was murdered on her way home
from school in california in 1973. 45
years later the newport beach police
department brought new attention to her
case by asking millions of people on
twitter for tips tracy smith has the
story for this week's 48 hours
hi i'm linda o'keefe 45 years ago today
i disappeared from newport beach
on july 6 2018 exactly 45 years after
linda o'keefe disappeared the newport
beach police department launched their
unusual campaign for new leads on the
cold case on twitter
i was murdered and my body was found in
the back bay
today i'm going to tell you my story
the last day of linda's life and its
tragic end unfolded in a series of
tweets written from the 11 year old
murder victim's point of view
when a victim speaks we want to listen
former newport beach pd spokesperson
jennifer manzella came up with the idea
after lead investigator sergeant court
deppwig tasked her with bringing
attention to the case we needed to
put linda's face out there
what was it like reading that twitter
story and essentially hearing linda's
voice
i thought that was the most incredible
gut-wrenching thing i have ever read
linda's former classmate lisa
christopher was one of the last people
to see her alive in july 1973.
linda was on the phone with her mother
in the school office begging her for a
ride home she was upset crying
just very very sad linda's sister cindy
borgeson had overheard her mother's end
of the phone call and my mom said
i'm really busy you can just walk home
less than an hour later eyewitnesses
said they spotted linda talking to a man
in a turquoise van
her body was found the next day along a
nature trail
who had murdered linda o'keefe
newport beach police were convinced
twitter would help them finally answer
that question
linda is going to help us find this man
who did this to her
my name is linda o'keefe
what is his name
[Music]
tracy how did twitter lead police to the
suspect after all of these years
well the story was seen around the world
and while it didn't lead them directly
to the killer what it did do is once
they had a suspect and they did get a
suspect they were able to search all of
his electronic devices they had probable
cause and that the evidence that they
found on those electronic devices could
really help them in trial
that is the power of social media thank
you so much tracy you can watch tracy's
report hashtag linda's story tomorrow on
48 hours at 10 9 central right here on
cbs